[Music]
what's going on guys you know one of the
most fun things we do here around screen
junkies is movie fights that's the show
where we debate the burning questions
that drive fans insane but you know
what's even crazier than movie fights a
drunk movie fights that's where we add
whiskey bourbon vodka beer and an Andy
signore's case Mike's Hard Lemonade into
the equation today we're gonna go behind
the scenes we're gonna pull back the
curtain and show you what happens once
the booze starts flowing and the
fighters start fighting get ready to
catch a little buzz check it out how's
it going my name is max I am the
producer of movie fights right now it is
an hour before showtime basically we're
making sure the scripts done I'm making
all the graphics making sure we have the
speed round questions you'd think that
would be done you know far in advance
but no comes out of the wire obviously
movie fights is totally made up but
there is a script
it's a Word document check it out this
is probably not very exciting but this
is what I do behind the scenes a lot of
Word documents a lot of photoshop it's
not all glitz and glamour
hey I'm LAN I'm a writer and researcher
here move a couple days before the show
is when I really get started with my
work which is just coming up with
questions that we should be debating I
mean the ultimate sort of debates of the
week a lot of it is based around the
news or what's opening back weekend in
theatres so I can start on it early in
the week I'll start working on speed
round on Wednesday we really don't
finalize them until a few hours before
movie fights till sometimes like a half
an hour it really comes down to the wire
yes I'm actually producing the behind
the scenes of movie fights as well so
this is like producing myself I think
it's like producing inception producing
producing it's pretty deception but also
we should go it's like 50 minutes before
beauty fights right now you're producing
the behind the scenes of movie fight
I've had at least five cups of coffee
today I'm so tired
oh hey guys just taking care of some
important business in there so let's go
check out the actual movie fight set Wow
drunk movie fights we've got Andy signor
can nap sock Elisha Malone and Dan Merle
hosting hey bring the camera what do you
think of this final this is a
championship match what do you think we
have three fighters who all have
different styles they come at it from
different angles
Andy signor some people call him a
lightweight I'm not here to disagree
with that Ken nap sock one of the most
charismatic drunks that you'll ever find
lovable likeable
maybe the people's champion of drunk
movie fights and then Alicia Malone a
mystery an enigma I've never seen Alicia
Malone uncollapse standing here with
James who is making drinks for our movie
fighters James you have any strategy as
far as these drinks are you making them
making them uh heavy are you making them
light oh they're so heavy they're really
heavy and right now Alicia is had more
than everyone Wow
yeah and she's now out for the end so I
think I kind of screwed her up although
I do have to say that everyone except
Alicia is one ahead but everyone else
has had the exact same amount I love
tequila
he's you're almost akela what kind of
bartending experience that do you have
that qualifies you for this job
oh absolutely none thank you I'm here
with Mark and Draco movie fighter former
drunk movie fighter and all-around swell
guy
mark tell me about your experience with
drunk movie fights I've done it as with
a contestant and it's a judge and this
is by far the most fascinating I feel a
little like Jane Goodall watching Apes
and their natural habitat hoping they
don't maul me all right all right I'm
following max Dion's orders so if you
remember on the drunk fights we had a
quick trick question so right now
remember this is what is the worst right
watch this
no it's what is the best see that's all
it is
it's all it takes quick quick typing and
and then I change people's whole
fighting experience and that's the power
that I have you've all been had because
this is a new feature that we have on
our show welcome to my world Alicia and
so what you have to do right now it's
explained to me why the movie you just
named is the best film starring since
this is drunk we'll be fightin and is
competing I will be judging today which
means that he can't know what the
speeder on questions are so usually we
roll into a show with about six speed
round questions that are set we know
what order they're going to be in
because this is drunk movie fights we
decided let's roll in with a couple of
extra ones because you want to play the
vibe of the room see who's in the speed
round because drunk movie fights as
movie fights but more than that it's
supposed to be fun so we're changing
things up a little inside I'm at speed
run it's so chaotic it's in seven extra
ammo just a case so I've narrowed it
down to like these bargain bin which we
decided was a ballboy LARP one and two
versus grown-ups wanted that's a
nightmare I had a man die in my arms and
chic shoes in 2001 that was a scene in
paul blart mall cop that doesn't count
so we're moving on the next question
would you rather become a gremlin or a
mini I think Andy took down the minions
with that level of luck I think that was
Jerry
besides Brad Pitt who is the hottest
Mouse alright to play off Ken's sure
classic question yeah Tom Hiddleston Tom
Hiddleston dan Tom Hiddleston checks off
a lot of genres of people looking for
sex right well 30 seconds I mean have
you seen those ABS this is all the
contingent on Ken making it break best
movie to put on you and your drinking
alone that's good yeah that's gonna be
super depressing Ken why is Casablanca
the best movie to put on when you
then I'm a lonely man dan I have no
purpose to my life [ __ ] don't be nice
to have a purpose to take down the Nazis
Andy the rock I mean he got it yeah
best intoxicated performance character
not actors Benicio del Toro and fear
loathing Las Vegas Brad Pitt true
romance Brad Pitt is in true romance I
can't remember said the common person
that's right Brad Pitt romance is for
gun he's just in a couch with a beard
going hey where you going at it's such a
understated beautiful nuanced
performance he reached into the depths
of his soul and found a way to make an
argument and that is why I have to give
the inaugural drunk movie fights
championship belt - mr. kidnaps
[Applause]
[Music]
I am here with the newly crowned drunk
movie fights champion and that's how
I've got a P so let's make this
interview real quick absolutely I think
it's great I think I earned it but I
also think Alicia Malone and Andy signor
did a great job and I I'm so honored for
this title I'm gonna defend it with much
honor what do you say to people who say
and you're the you're the head of screen
junkies it's unprofessional to get drunk
on on the YouTube uh I mean I think you
could you can do that I think we keep it
we keep it you know at a level it
doesn't get there have you seen me
can you see how ugly and old I am I have
a hot wife it totally happens we're not
ripping her clothes off saying sex
things like that's true that's true
we are not ripping our clothes off
saying sex things Alicia you were a big
fan favorite coming into this fight and
you did not make it to the speed round
thoughts thoughts a feeling I'm happy I
want to drink drunk and to win because I
felt that he would do the best Dan Merle
what was it like judging this drunk
movie fights it's very difficult I am
the current movie fights champion I had
to crown a champion it was a bit of a
different circumstance than usual I'm a
little drunk right now I'm a lot drunk
right now I had to go with who really
dipped into the reserve when the time
came ken was out of it he was gone he
was away from this fight every time it
counted he dug deep into himself and
found the will to make a great argument
had to give two kidnaps are there gonna
be more drunk movie fights in the future
I mean I think that I've had a lot of
interest for people who want to fight
drunk drunk fights I think we'll have to
do another round see who is up to the
task and if mr. Ken knapsacks willing to
put that belt up I think we find the
best the best to go up against him again
I'm down if he is how do you prepare for
drunk movie fight I just get drunk hell
Wow one drink at a time
absolutely Oh a true champion he earned
it he's the people's champion and now
he's the true drunk movie fights
champion thank getting up thank you well
that was a good time
what did you think was the drunkest and
do you have any good drunk movie fights
questions for us let us know in the
comments section below
we want to know and
maybe we'll use your questions I want to
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye hey guys did you know that this end
card works with your phone now I know
right click the boxes below to watch
more screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more